jetzt schauen wir noch mal auf den
angekündigten flughafen streik vom
mittwoch an verdi das bodenpersonal der
lufthansa will streiken und das
ausgerechnet jetzt wo ohnehin schon das
große chaos herrscht
flughafen frankfurt 10 uhr morgens
warteschlangen und koffer berge so weit
das auge reicht flüge gestrichen die
menschen frustriert der flughafen
frankfurt ein sinnbild für das deutsche
reise disaster und inmitten dieser
urlaubs krise jetzt der nächste glaubt
die gewerkschaft verdi ruft zum streik
auf wir gehen davon aus dass dem
frankfurt und münchen zu starken
beeinträchtigungen vielen
flugannullierungen kommen wird wenn ich
sogar der ganze luftverkehr der
lufthansa an dem tag zum erliegen kommt
20.000 beschäftigte des lufthansa
bodenpersonals sollen ihre arbeit
niederlegen und ein signal an den flug
gigant senden mehr gehalt mehr personal
weniger arbeit es ist das nächste
debakel an deutschen flughäfen seit
wochen dominieren diese bereits den
negativschlagzeilen
denn corona bedingt wurde das
flughafenpersonal zur mangelware die
folge gestrichene und verpasste flüge
genervte urlauber deutschlandweit auch
die fehlenden gepäckabfertigung sorgen
für bilder wie diese vom flughafen in
berlin unzählige herrenlose koffer
gepackt für den sommerurlaub doch liegen
gelassen am ber die verantwortung hier
bei den angestellten der airlines nicht
zuletzt bei verdi bild weiß dass die
gepäckstück ihrem eigentümer
ausgehändigt werden kann bis kommendes
jahr dauern
nach zwei jahren pandemie einem tobenden
krieg in europa und mega inflation
wollen die deutschen endlich ihren
wohlverdienten sommerurlaub antreten
doch fehlendes personal und jetzt wer
die sorgen für urlaubsfotos stand
urlaubslust dann einfach lieber bahn
fahren oder
und besser nicht fäuste fliegen frauen
schreien und schubsen sich gegenseitig
aus einer regionalbahn die nachfrage
nach dem 9 euro ticket groß zu groß wie
der andrang auf den letzten zug vom
timmendorfer strand vom wochenende
belegt anstatt nordseeluft und
entspannung gibt eskalation im zug drei
polizeiwagen müssen anrücken nur so kann
der sitzplatz streit entschärft werden
auf bild anfrage weist die bahn jede
verantwortung von sich
[Musik]